- Dans cette communauté
autochtone de 400 résidents,
peu se souviennent de l'époqueùe
consommée en toute sécurité.
À Neskantaga, dans le nord de
l'Ontario, l'avis ébullition
de l'eau est entrér
en 1995 et n'a jamais été levé
depuis.
Services aux Autochtones Canada
espère que l'avis sera levé
avant que la communauté
franchisse un autre triste
record. Pour cela, Ottawa
a annoncé un investissement pour
moderniser l'usine de traitement
de l'eau de Neskantaga en 2016.
Mais des problèmes avec
le fournisseur ont entre autres
ralenti ce processus et
des tests doivent encore être
effectués avant de pouvoir
ficiellement
l'avis d'ébullition. À cela
s'ajoute aussi la confiance
qu'il faudra rétablir.
Avec ce triste record,
10 000 jours sans eau potable,
soit 27 ans et 4 mois,
c'est toute une génération
qui a grandi en se méfiant
de l'eau. Une eau non potable
qui a aussi entraîné
des problèmes de peau
chez certains membres
de la communauté,
en plus de bouleverser
leur vie quotidienne.
Au Canada, 34 avis d'ébullition
de l'eau sont toujours en
vigueur dans les communautés
autochtones, dont la grande
majorité en Ontario.
À Neskantaga, Services
aux Autochtones Canada espère
pouvoir lever l'avis
d'ébullition de l'
d'ici l'automne prochain,
mais plusieurs membres de
la communauté sont sceptiques.
Ce n'est pas la première foisque
de promesse.
Ici Aya Dufour,
Radio-Canada, Sud